Danica Patrick is joining us the retired
professional racing driver that's me
yeah retired yeah happily okay
people ask what I do I'm like go on
vacations when's the last time you drove
over 100 miles an hour
well I accidentally almost go that fast
in Green Bay because there's like five
lanes and no cars so I go fast there but
I did some ride-alongs
I did some two-seater rides at Sonoma
about a month or two ago and actually I
had a lot of fun did you ever make
somebody cry or throw up in the car on
the ride-along
yes ooh I remember the first time I
remember that was back in it was South
Carolina I was at like a BMW M school
and this is back when I drove for them
which was a long long time ago and I was
doing some schools and so part of it was
a road course and sort of there was some
slalom in it and there was a dad and his
son and the dad the dad went threw up I
also think there was one other time I
drove a rich billionaire around for his
birthday peleonero yeah it was a rich
Russian billionaire that was having his
42nd birthday and I was asked to drive
him around Laguna and I drove around
Laguna and I thought after lap one he
was like yay so much fun he was tapping
out but we did another lap and I think
he threw up after that what track do you
think you could make me throw up we're
scared any of them oh really
yeah Road course is more so I would
think but people have a real discomfort
for driving next to the wall so if I
drove next to the wall somewhere you'd
probably get a little uncomfortable all
right let me give you the like Las Vegas
like I get a little nervous there
probably okay yeah that's just because
you're hungover Danica Patrick is
launched for a podcast pretty intense
that's the name of it where she speaks
with some of the biggest names in food
nutrition business science and
entertainment so now you're on the other
side of the microphone they're asking
questions being curious listening who do
you most want to interview that you have
it Oprah okay have you made inroads with
Oprah
I mean we did we touched base with
Oprah's crew about a couple different
things but you know I I don't have her
cell so okay but what what is it that
you're curious about with Oprah her
spiritual journey one of the things that
really got me um deeper into the
spiritual journey the internal the
looking internally is super soul Sunday
have you ever seen that no no on own and
she interviews people like Don Miguel
Ruiz and brené Brown and people that are
really insightful spiritual healing
people so yeah I just would love to know
how that began for her I'm curious how
racing began for you because you know
normally you don't have I have three
daughters I would be shocked if one at
age eight goes you know I think I want
to be a professional driver like what
age do you say to your parents this is
what I want to do well I was ten and
before I wanted to be a driver I wanted
to be a veterinarian a singer and a
secretary wait all at the same time or
in that order like well those are all
dreams before I was ten okay what was
your fault what were you gonna do if you
didn't race cars I never had to think
about that I mean at 16 I left high
school to go race in England so at that
point in time my junior year that's
usually when you're thinking about what
the heck am I gonna do next what college
am I gonna go to and I was going to
college in England for racing so like I
was pursuing it when I came back I
didn't have a job and at that point in
time I could have thought to myself
jeez this GED might not be me so well
because I did get it I did fail though
the first time should be known that I
failed the GED the first time because of
the Constitution test I passed
everything else no problem but the
Constitution test you had to get 30 out
of 60 right and obviously that means I
didn't get 30 out of 60 right so I had
to retake that part of it but yeah at
that point I didn't have a ride for you
know two years really and
I could have thought to myself at that
point but I had just so much blind faith
that it was gonna work out yeah but how
do you know or - how does somebody know
you're good well your lap time is fast
but that's it yes so if I know if you
have a quick lap time then I know that
you have the potential like that's that
that's the first thing I'm looking for
yeah good lap time good feedback honesty
you don't crash the car yeah you're on
time you're professional who tried to
talk you out of it
driving yeah no one really no one
parents my dad loved Ranger my dad loves
racing more than I do so he definitely
wasn't talking me out of it my mom and
dad met on a blind date at a race so
she's clearly into it and then my sister
started when I started when we were kids
I mean she was she was there in the
beginning so yeah how do you satisfy
that competitiveness like what do you do
now to kind of fill in that void
other than the streets of Green Bay High
I mean the all all the things that I do
now with whether it's the podcast and
learning how to get better at that I
mean every time I do a show and ever and
there's people standing in the room
afterwards I go if there's anything you
see that I need to do different just
tell me like I'm coachable I want to
know I'm not offended
so the competitiveness in me comes out
with other jobs my wine somnium growing
that and selling more wine so it's not
so it's not quite as much instant
gratification as you get with a lap time
or a finish result yeah so yeah I do
miss a little bit of that part of it cuz
it was so easy to quantify you know you
qualify in the poll or you qualify xxx
those are pretty different did you enjoy
the experience like racing yeah went by
pretty quick it feels like because
sometimes we don't yeah like it seems
like just yesterday Dan we were doing a
sports center commercial where I parked
in
parking spot patrick said d patrick
there but it was crazy even then for you
because i think you were flying you had
to be done at a certain time because you
were flying by helicopter to letterman
does that sound right yeah that might be
right actually yeah you're right yeah so
it's but it's like you kind of look back
and even my guys who've been around me
for 17 years they'll go do you remember
when we did and I don't remember those
things because you kind of keep moving
constantly moving you were constantly
trying to prove yourself or prove
yourself you know to your own self or to
other people and all of that then you
kind of look back and you wake up and
you go got it
what happened or it's over do you ever
think to yourself I still need to prove
oh yeah every day really oh absolutely
there are what are some markers that
would tell you just me yeah it's just me
some but like some big moments where
you're like okay yeah you know that's
that's pretty cool it is but I can I I
have a problem of looking back even when
I hosted the Olympics limit had done
batter that would have been a marker in
timer you could have gone that was
pretty cool you think I accomplished
some great things handing out the Super
Bowl trophy not to your boyfriend but
handing out this Super Bowl trophy and
always this year yeah well I I'm not
doing it anymore but I I still look back
and I know I could have been better I
still beat myself up over not asking
Nick Foles a question about his daughter
on the podium when I'm handing him the
Super Bowl trophy because he had his
one-year-old there with her headphones
on and I was going to say what what are
you going to tell her about this moment
like I but I it still beats me up so you
like well you're great though is because
I feel like in greatness you can still I
mean as an example you know Aaron had
his fantastic game the other night
perfect
not that yeah his perfect game and I
said good job and there's still that
little moment of like well I think it
kind of felt effortless in some way and
it's like yeah well you know I'm sure
there's plenty other games where you
feel like you know what things were in
your favor and whether the defense
wasn't you know finding a way to get to
you or what
ever it was and it was a F more
effortless game and you have a few of
those a year and do you have perfect
games every time so it's a light Aaron
greatness you greatness like you're
always looking back and thinking what
could I have done differently or being
not dismissive but somewhat it's like
you think just you always think about
what you could have done and how to
improve but that's how you improve but
when you having been an athlete how does
that help you does it help you when you
watch him play a sport like it you were
in a dangerous sport he plays a
dangerous sport I don't know do you take
it do you have a different process than
somebody who was not in a profession
like you were in watching your your
boyfriend well I almost said husband
watch it whoa your boyfriend yeah is
there a process it's different for me
watching it do you think it's different
for me because I well I can only tell
you how I feel and that's that when I
watch I'm not nervous because the nerves
I felt like when I was nervous it was
because of things I had to do I think
there was a responsibility don't crash
his car you know be smart on restarts
miss accidents you know past that car
fuel the car push it to the limit try a
new line there was all kind of things I
had to do so I was nervous for like the
things that I had to do there's nothing
I have to do when he's playing football
so I'm not really nervous but I tell you
when he's still holding on to the ball
after a few seconds and I can you know
like I mean obviously he's great out of
the pocket but Annie escapes many many
many people trying to tackle him I do
get a little tense but watching the
charge I kids that okay okay babe okay
babe throw that ball okay okay babe but
watching the charger gets ya was under
duress there a couple times early and
that's not fun were you at the game no
okay what do you like to watch the game
with at home what do I like No what are
you like Oh
like if I'm there with you Oh are you
staying an obvious why it focused and I
jump up when things get good like if
there's a touchdown or something
just jump it's like many it's a mini
workout for me are you but I focus I
watch the whole thing and I've always
felt that way about sports whether
you're watching racing or football or
whatever your passion is if you don't
pay attention to the ebb and flow of the
of the game it's really hard to get a
feel for the game like just watching an
individual play is not that it's not
always that interesting I mean there's
always a couple of amazing plays in a
game but most aren't right it's a you
know five years rushing up the middle
and they fall down and you're like okay
but if you know the Abin flow of the
game and you know who has momentum and
who doesn't and then when you see a
breakthrough play you've realized oh boy
the tides have shifted right so I watch
very attentively we're talking to Danica
Patrick and she has a new podcast pretty
intense and how did people get your
podcast anywhere used in a podcast okay
because I'm on like podcast one I don't
I don't know well I mean it's on Apple
podcast five wherever you get your
pocket just wanted to be professional
here and make sure that I let people
know where they can find pretty intense
where she speaks to the biggest names in
food nutrition business science and
entertainment does Erin let you drive oh
yeah for sure is he any good yeah he's
actually a great driver yes he even
knows how to set up a corner naturally
wait what does that mean well if there's
a turn in apex exit and the angles one
one driver in the house yeah Paulie turn
an apex exit and so he knows how to set
it up and he knows that apex the corner
and yeah he's a good driver you're not a
backseat driver though like you don't
critique it I mean a little a little
like oh you had it or you could have
gone you know that's usually the most
common time people don't calculate
things right is there there holes and
gaps where they could turn in or
whatever I see those like I'm visually
so attuned to the closing rates and to
how much space I have I also am pretty
tuned into
having small spaces and finding bending
away so that's about it but he's a great
driver if you were going to help NASCAR
now and you can make one change did you
see that Roger Penske bought IndyCar
Series AMS productions and the
Indianapolis Motor Speedway he's got a
lot of money Wow I we were trying to
talk about how much they are you coming
back
no god no that was fascinating I thought
you know there was telling me you know
the helmet George family has owned those
four you know yeah
70s plus years so it's yeah forever so
it's it's just it was just big news but
you're asking about a NASCAR what would
I do
yeah change one thing mm-hmm
make all the radios live so you can hear
all the dialogue at all times all right
are they can you listen to all everybody
everybody Oh Paulie you used to have be
able to unserious
they used to have the driver pass where
you could hear it but it was also
censored so if there was any swearing it
there wasn't censor they would get
exciting I love I think I always made
the hit list after the weekend because I
swore a bit were you so that was normal
though why you're in the heat of the
moment it be like wouldn't you love to
hear what was going on at during any
game with the athletes talking wouldn't
you want to know we just want to hear
that we just want to hear literally
what's being said on the line in a
football game wouldn't you want to hear
what's being said out there on the like
in a hockey game with those guys with no
teeth I mean that would be fantastic so
I think that's interesting but
fundamentally I mean there's just so
there's so many great areas in NASCAR to
push the envelope and I mean that exists
everywhere but yeah I don't know it if
it was that easy we'd do it right if
there was one easy but we're missing
something with NASCAR are we yes what do
you what don't do what what is it
missing this they're not stars they're
not stars the way they can be better
drivers more accomplished drivers but
we're missing we're missing Stewart you
got Earnhardt not there Gordon not there
you're not there
and the you were not you were more than
just a NASCAR driver okay so that would
probably come down to a little bit more
of sponsorship you know when a big
driver you know doesn't have a sponsor
they go away right that happened an
IndyCar to big drivers wouldn't have
sponsors and then money would come in
and they would get the job and they
might be from another country they might
be someone unknown and that doesn't
develop the personalities of a sport if
you don't have consistent names so I
mean that that that's a big part of it
like Denny Hamlin has a personality and
he's not afraid and then you'll have
these dust ups there and then you get
like Joey Logano like you'll get
attention for that I love those fights
don't you love the fight those two are
always good for him but how did you how
did you almost hit oh like there was a I
feel like there was like a there was
like a side by side with Denny of like
were you more scared of Joey or more
scared of Danica because I was like I
grabbed onto his suit because he took me
out twice a Daytona yeah but did you
want to punch him yes of course I did
did you come close oh I grabbed a suit
though it's probably borderline okay but
III was yeah I was fired up and you
could take case he came yeah he doesn't
race anymore either
yeah but you could have taken yeah he's
pretty right you know he's just too nice
we won't talk about he's fit but I think
he's like endurance fit yeah he's a tiny
guy you could take I wish you the best
with your podcast and you come on Dan I
would love to absolutely I'd be honored
and if I could help you in any way with
this whole goofy medium that we have now
that you're in I'd be more than happy to
help you the landscape of media is so
much different what is your favorite
what is your favorite new element of
media I don't think I have any this
simulcast I love because what I tried to
do with the simulcast is create movement
where you have TV cameras but then I put
a basketball gym in golf simulator we
move around I wanted to give you kind of
behind the scenes not just one camera
that you'll see on a simulcast I want
you to see
when we're not on radio we're on TV
behind the scenes and that to me was
fascinating that that's what I wanted to
give the audience and almost like a
voyeuristic you get to watch us without
us really acknowledging you so that's
something that that's interesting for me
you aren't afraid you do or say some oh
yeah we do it I mean we've had butt
crack shown we've had you know partial
nudity we've had language but that but
that's real some you know I mean who
doesn't want a little nudity depends on
the person for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]